Wow. Bruce, a little help now.
You guys got It. Welcome back everyone, Happy Holidays
This will be my full Marvel
What If Season 2 Episode 3 video
It's basically their Christmas episode
There's a whole bunch of Easter Eggs
and references here, so we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the episodes
and careful for spoilers.
If you haven't seen the episode yet, we'll just start
at the beginning, work our way through, shot by shot.
Talking about Easter eggs in WTF moments.
starting with the episode title.
What if Happy Hogan saved Christmas with Happy Hogan
essentially becoming
a version of the freak version of his character
from the older Marvel Comics
in a parody of the Die Hard movie with him
being kind of like the John McClane character,
except in the episode they use him
as more of like a purple version of the Hulk.
so is basically
what if Happy Hogan turned into the Hulk, no.
Know when you're beat, freak.
If you're not a big comic book reader.
Happy Hogan became the Freak
during Tales of Suspense number 74.
It was kind of an Iron Man story, like he got involved
with a bunch of Iron Man's technology
and accidentally was turned into the freak
like his face changed everything about him, changed.
He wound up having to fight Iron Man
for a little while to Iron Man was able to stop him
and then take his powers away
the creators of the show actually said part of the deal
that got Jon Favreau to come back
and do The voice for Happy Hogan in season one
is that when he came back
he said, okay, I'll do this, but during season two,
you have to give me my own episode and you have to
let me become a version of the freak from the comics.
so this episode was basically their way
of paying that off during the Marvel intro,
they play an Avengers
themed version of the 12 Days of Christmas song.
generally, throughout the entire episode,
there's a bunch of different holiday types
of references, different movies, different songs,
all kinds of holiday themed things.
This time the Watcher appears a little bit more fully,
confirming my theory that just like in season one,
like you see a little bit more of him in each episode
until eventually he starts revealing himself
to the actual characters in the different universes
He claims that Christmas is his favorite time of year.
He spends his time
watching all these different universes.
So it is interesting to know that Christmas
is his favorite time of year And he uses that to tell
a Christmas story about this particular universe.
pretty much everybody from the Marvel movies
came back to voice their characters again,
with a few exceptions.
Jon Favreau came back to do Happy Hogan.
Kat Dennings came back to do Darcy
Cobie Smulders came back to do Marial
Jeremy Renner came back to do Hawkeye.
Mark Ruffalo came back to do Bruce Banner,
Hulk Sam Rockwell came back to do Just that.
Hammer we might also be getting him back in the live
action MCU movies eventually to Chris
Hemsworth was back
is Thor Lake Bell does the voice for Black widow
though she did it during season one,
so she just came back to do more Black Widow.
she was also recently in Black Panther.
Wakanda Forever is like a completely different
character.
Did the same person who plays Iron Man in season one
come back for season two it if you didn't recognize him
Josh Keaton does the voice of Captain America
like he'll do it Captain America in other episodes too.
But he's also most notably
The Voice of spectacular Spider-Man,
who just did a big cameo scene
as that character in Spider-Man across the Spider-Verse
Maria Hill
places this in the timeline, saying it's
the first Christmas after the events of Avengers
Age of Ultron, saying that the Christmas needs to go
well because of the year they've had is kind of rough.
pretty much everything in this universe
is similar to the way things went down in the MCU
with like one exception to what happened to Justin
Hammer after the events of Iron Man two.
Like, that's the only thing that changed
the camera zooms in on the snow globe
that the watcher starts
reciting the Night before Christmas poem to set up
the Thor bookend At the end of the episode
where Thor completes the poem.
in they pick up in the middle of the Avengers
fight against Happy Hogan Hulk,
Notice all the stockings for all the different Avengers
hanging above the chimney.
This is inside that top level where their lounge,
the bar was in Avengers Age of Ultron.
Were they their big party at
They played the game to see who could lift
Thor's hammer.
They're all dressed in Christmas attire
because they were off doing different things,
some of them on other missions, some of them doing
charity work, some of them trying to get toys.
The watcher does that storytelling
trope, the record scratch moment where he's like,
pause things like, he pauses.
This universe, we should probably tell you how things
started and then rewinds to the beginning of the story.
right. You're probably wondering who this guy is.
Perhaps I should start a bit further back
They make a minor change with the what if intro scene
blending happy Hogan Hulk with it, making it purple
for a second, but the rest of the intro is the exact
same as all the other episodes.
They explain that in this universe, The Avengers
are about to have a holiday charity gala in Happy.
Hogan's in charge of getting the tower ready
like he did during Spider-Man homecoming,
basically doing the same type of thing,
like background organizational stuff.
end, while
they're doing this,
they just also happen to have Jarvis off line
dragging, just getting ready to upgrade his systems,
There are a couple inconsistencies
though like Jarvis should still not be online
inside the Avengers tower
but on Happy Hogan's phone later in the episode
he has Hallie Keener.
So like it's after the events of Iron Man three,
which happened after Age of Ultron
when Iron Man started using the Friday.
I the whole idea in the MCU is that Jarvis essentially
was destroyed by Ultron,
But then he wound up becoming part of vision.
Like, vision is the baby of both Ultron and Jarvis.
I think that was just an oversight
on the part of the people that were making the episode.
Like he knows
Harley Quinn or Iron Man three is happens.
That's how he has Harley Quinn, his phone number.
But also the Iron Legion is still around
and they're still using the Jarvis
I They explained that at this point in history,
Darcy is interning at The Avengers Tower.
They make a couple of jokes about her
being a perpetual intern.
Like she's never actually had a paying job.
Like she just always interns everywhere she goes.
She also makes a joke
about being perpetually in college.
Like, if you want college credit for this,
you're going to have to do what I say
In reality, she's incredibly smart.
She has like several advanced degrees.
That's why she's in college for so long,
like she's in university
getting these PhDs,
she makes a Barnard, an accounting reference.
That's a callback to what if season
one in another reality, that was another accountant
that wanted to get with Captain Carter
but in this reality because things are a little bit
more like they were in the MCU.
Steve Rogers is Captain America Darcy's Parakeet
joke is a callback to Iron Man two with Whiplash,
his parakeet that he had in that movie.
They never explained
what happened to the parakeet after the ending,
and it turned into a big meme in the fandom.
Like everyone's was like,
Whatever happened to that parakeet?
We're never going to know.
We're never going to find out happy.
Hogan tells her to get more maraschino cherries to get
rid of her, basically because they have an entire jar.
And Iron Man doesn't drink hot toddies anymore
because he's a recovering alcoholic,
Cobie Smulders comes back is Maria Hill in the episode
when she references having a bad year.
Like I said, it's the aftermath of Avengers
Age of Ultron.
Darcy talks about her Hanukkah playlist
because if he didn't realize she's Jewish
inside the MCU, Mariah Carey,
though, is just like a general holiday mainstay.
she's probably made more money on her holiday albums
than any other recording artist in history.
The Christmas song of Mariah Carey's This On
Loop is a reference to All I Want for Christmas,
which she later congratulated Justin Hammer
for when he uses that song in his Wordplay.
Justin Hammer
then enters the Avengers tower, finishing the night
before Christmas poem, reciting the ending,
which Thor also does.
At the end of the episode In the Watcher
makes a reference to how the Grinch Stole Christmas,
basically explaining
how his history went differently in this universe.
Like during the events of Iron Man two,
he gets thrown in prison after that movie happens
and just thinks of a plan to steal Iron
Man's technology, then finds out about the Hulk blood.
It wants to give himself powers Notice
in his magazine in prison, too.
There's a reference to the science prose
and the cooking meme.
Like, What is he cooking? What are they cooking?
this is also where the plot of the episode
kind of turns into a die hard
parody with him being kind of like Alan
Rickman's character, Hans Gruber.
notices using Russian goons again,
just like in Iron Man two.
Vanko was Russian.
he pretends to use the plot of the Christmas Story
movie as his own childhood,
which everybody recognizes instantly.
Like, everybody in the room is like, Wait a minute.
Isn't that the plot of a movie fun fact to some of you
probably realize this, but the main star of that
movie, Peter Billingsley, also wound up playing
William Ginter Riva in the first Iron Man movie,
then came back in Spider-Man far from home
as part of the mysterious plot.
he takes control of the Iron Legion
when he calls them Johnny Vibes.
That's another movie reference to Short Circuit.
They make a lot of references to movies in general,
not just holiday movies, but movies in general.
During this episode, Darcy starts
singing a version of Good King Wenceslas
with herself and Steve Rogers,
Captain America inserted into the lyrics.
She also does the full version of the song
during the Post-Credits scene.
This is like the first episode
that actually has a post-credits scene.
the whole plot here with Justin Hammer
wanting the Hulk blood to turn himself
into a version of the Hulk is something
they literally just did on the She-Hulk series.
Everybody wanting the Hawks blood to become versions
of the holds or replicate the powers of the Hulk.
Somehow.
they're also supposed to turn Thunderbolt Ross
into a version of Red Hulk during Captain America four.
so a lot of Hulk related stuff
just happening in the MCU right now.
Like we just got scar son of hulk to reportedly
Marvel is also working on their new solo Hulk movie.
Supposedly
they figured out whatever their deal with Universal
was behind the scenes,
but no idea when that movie would actually happen.
Just an hammer makes another Sokovia reference
to hiring Sokovia and goons instead of Russian goons.
Then they do more literal die hard references
where happy Hogan starts crawling
through the elevator shaft in the vents,
just like John McClane.
we find out that Iron Man has his own
special private bathroom in the Avengers Tower.
It makes sense that he would have this.
He owns everything like that belongs to him
financially.
So he probably have his own private sanctuaries
around the tower.
Kind of sounds like Justin Hammer wants to leave him
and Upper Deck are going to leave him
a little present for Christmas
there are a bunch of Christmas songs
throughout the episode, the one that he plays here
when he goes into the lounge is Broadway Jingling.
Most of the other songs,
though, are Christmas themed songs.
they imply that Iron Man's actual true villain,
like the only thing he's
actually afraid of is having to pay taxes
because he's so wealthy.
Just an hammer also implies that he learned
martial arts while he was in Sergei Prison.
That might be a sly reference to the Shang Shi movie
because of what happened with Wenwu
The ten rings coming to abduct Trevor
in that being such a heavy martial arts themed movie,
this place that Happy Hogan gets
into where they're storing
the Hawks blood is just one of the other storage
facilities for projects
they're working on like a science bro's storage shed,
basically glorified storage shed.
he clocks Hawkeye's confetti arrow,
which he uses later in the episode.
Also using it to joke
clowning on Hawkeye, renting him out for parties.
they make a bunch of Hawkeye jokes in this episode
about how unpopular is a character he is.
somewhere out there.
Kate Bishop is being offended by all this, in happy
accidentally gets injected
with the gamma serum and starts
turning into a purple hulk.
But he's also meant to be a reference
to the freak version of his character.
I just like they're using him as more of a purple
hulk in the episode he winds up in the room
where they create the new Avengers suits
with copies of their old suits on display.
They make a couple of spandex jokes
in here to the purple spandex
is for the Hulk's spandex pants
that don't rip when he grows.
later they make another die hard reference
when he uses it to jump to the lower floor.
John McClane did something similar in the Die
Hard movie, the I love L.A.
coffee mug on the desk,
I think is also meant to be a reference to the suit
maker in Los Angeles during the She-Hulk series,
where Daredevil also went to get his new suits made
They've got posters of the Avengers
all over this room, too,
including posters of their holiday suits
that they made them for this particular episode,
like their actual superhero suits
that are just holiday themed
Happy flips through the contacts on his phone
and there are a bunch, a bunch of references.
So just starting at the top, working our way down.
A Bradley is A.C. Bradley.
She's one of the showrunners on the What If TV
series and Chauncey is one of the other showrunners.
Everhart.
Here is Christine Everhart from the Iron Man movies.
Jeff Fisher is one of the editors on What if,
like a lot of these people are just crew members,
then he's got Nick Fury, Maria Hills number below him,
H Keener is Harley
Keener from Iron Man three Confirming this
is that after the events of Iron Man three
see Kline is Cameron Clyne, who was a shield coworker
of Maria Hills during Winter Soldier.
Astley is obviously Stan Lee.
Jay Lincoln is Janice Lincoln, a.k.a.
Lady Beetle, who's from the Captain America Comics.
She's also the daughter of Tombstone.
She's appeared in some of the Spider-Man
comics in the past, then we get
Pepper Potts below her, Rhodey below her Steve Rogers.
Below him
General Thunderbolt Ross below Him Black Widow.
Then Tony Stark.
Sam Wilson at the bottom,
who's still Falcon at this point in history.
then he calls Black Widow,
who's at the Russian ballet performance of Nutcracker
in another part of town, taking out a foreign assassin.
the other thing about this, too, I think is a bit of
a Black widow reference, because all the black widows
that go through the red Room are trained in ballet,
even black Widow Natasha herself,
Iron Man and Captain America are playing
Santa and his elf at a charity event.
And he's getting salty because the little kid
sounds like he would rather have a captain America
shield as a Christmas toy than an Iron Man toy
in Captain America is getting mobbed by all the Milfs
that want America's ass Bruce Banner and Hawkeye
are doing a parody of the Schwarzenegger movie Jingle
All the Way,
which is a Christmas movie where he battles Sinbad over
getting the last remaining Turbo Man toy
before Christmas.
they even gave Hawkeye
some of the dialog from the jingle
all the way movies saying that he can't return home.
Like his wife said, Don't come home without the toy,
Obviously the joke here clowning on
Hawkeye is that he's not popular.
Nobody wants to buy his toys.
Like only one person bought a Hawkeye toy.
It was probably Kay Bishop or a younger
version of the character or They're basically trying
to dump them here, like they discounted them to 25%
to try and get rid of them.
But all the Iron Man toys are almost sold out,
like there's one left
because he's such a popular character in there.
Logos are also the same logos from their comics,
Bruce Banner is wearing a Christmas sweater.
There's another reference to the science Bruce.
He makes a Hulk joke
saying that the sun's getting real low,
implying that if Hawkeye doesn't give him that Iron Man
toy to the little girl,
he'll turn into the Hulk and smash him Dancing, happy,
make a bunch of movie references.
Con Air, which was Nicolas Cage.
He also played ghostwriter in the Marvel movies
Under Siege.
Was Steven Seagal, happy Makes the die hard reference.
Darcy
also makes a blockbuster video reference in real life.
I've actually got my rental car from Blockbuster,
so all those things are like collector's items now.
So let me know if you actually still
have your rental car from Blockbuster to She also calls
Nick Fury the scary dude with the eyepatch
they introduce the subbasement of the Avengers tower.
We've never actually been there before.
Like, there are a couple places in the Avengers tower
they visit in this episode that we've never been Darcy
also references Reginald Bell Johnson,
who was also in the Die Hard movie and he was also
in a deleted scene from Avengers Endgame, meant to show
what Professor Hulk was doing before the events.
When he shows up in the diner,
they wound up getting rid of the scene.
But for like a brief second, Reginald Bell
Johnson was in the Marvel movies
when he destroys the punching bag.
That's also a reference to Captain America
doing the same thing in the first Avengers movie.
all the men running through the stairs
also reminded me of Hulk from Endgame
like Hulk versus stares
Darcy makes a Darth Vader Star Wars reference.
Star Wars has been referenced
in a bunch of Marvel movies a bunch of different times.
So it's canon inside the MCU.
make all the Mace Windu Nick Fury jokes.
she makes the Chronicles of Narnia reference
and then goes through Iron Man's other suit eyes.
He doesn't have every single one here,
like they don't list them all, but there are several.
She binds.
Friday was words, I think is a reference to one of
the crew members working on the Marvel movies.
Edith Obviously a reference to the Edith Glasses
from Spider-Man far from home.
Werner is a reference to Wernher von Braun
from real life World War Two.
They started building rockets
for the United States, for NASA.
But in the episode, they use it
more as a Werner Herzog joke.
and in real life. Jon Favreau, who plays Happy Hogan.
He directed the first two Iron Man movies,
too, is also the showrunner on The Mandalorian
and was responsible for casting Werner
Herzog during season one.
Talk about Met at Easter Eggs and connections here.
Justin Hammer reveals he was going to use the hook blow
to turn himself into a hook and use it to make
people think that he was becoming a hero.
Redeeming himself.
Probably something similar would happen
during armor wars if he comes back trying to steal Iron
Man's technology, they make another reference to Iron
Man's Friday II when he calls Darcy your girl Friday.
that's actually the movie that Iron Man
got the name of the guy from.
It's a Cary Grant movie about a person
who falls in love with a woman that works for him
and it's a reference in the MCU to him
falling in love with Pepper Potts.
He makes a joke about Iron Man
getting Captain America Iron Man
themed socks as a joke based on their rivalry
between the two of them.
They pay off the joke with Hawkeye's confetti arrow,
and then Justin Hammer
takes the Hulkbuster
while happy destroys the entire Iron Legion.
So R.I.P. Press F to pay respects to the Iron Legion.
He also calls Happy Hogan Hulk Hogan.
then they make a bunch of Justin Hammer Santa Claus
references because he is wearing a giant red suit.
The Hulkbuster
Darcy makes a bunch of computer references
like The Pinwheel of Death is a mac reference control.
All delete is an oldie
but goodie Way to reboot your computer.
they make the Werner Herzog parody with the Werner A.I.
voice.
But it's not actually Werner Herzog coming back to do
the voice himself, When Happy's fighting Justin Hammer,
they use the same move that Iron Man used on the Hulk
in Avengers age of Voltron
to try and get him to stop by punching him repeatedly.
we get the Avengers back.
They fight happy Hogan Hulk for a hot second
till they realize what's actually going on.
And he shouts, Justin hammer out the window,
then saves them.
Presumably
they just threw him back into prison after this.
when he jokes about being stuck this way in the comics,
Happy Hogan did eventually turn into the freak again,
implying that he will turn into this purple
hulk eventually again, we get a little more holiday
wordplay from the Watcher, completing Iron Man's dialog
here about them going in for food.
then Thor shows up at the end of the episode.
It is Chris Hemsworth to finish the Watchers Night
before Christmas poem with him watching from the sky.
get a little more Christmas music playing
over the end credits and a surprise
post-credits scene
like the first one they've done this season so far.
All right, for her.
The giant neck it is full of muscles
Happy holidays.
this time is Darcy singing more of her Captain America
version of Good King Wenceslas.
But this time it's like the full version of the song
with The Avengers.
Characters inserted lyrics like a bunch of Thor stuff
in here to there's this special
thanks to Roy Thomas in the end credits here too
but it's in every single episode
because Roy Thomas was one of the Marvel comic
book creators that helped create the
What if comics There are a bunch of Easter eggs
and references in the episode.
So if you spotted any that
I didn't mention in the video, just write them below
in the comments in my full episode for video
we'll post tomorrow on actual Christmas Day.
So it's going to be the Iron Man on Sarkar episode.
It'll be the same person
playing the Iron Man character.
click here for that.
Update the link As soon as I post that and click here
for all my other what if episodes.
Thank you so much for watching
everyone Stay safe and happy holidays.